I mean we mentioned it before that there
is kind of a duality yeah there's a
public Persona and then there's a person
that isn't that public Persona sure does
that car I mean are there difficulties
that that causes in your life or well
are you just surrounded by enough people
that understand yes yeah I enjoy being
absolutely insane in public because this
is a very fun time yeah and I think
everyone else is saying let's maybe try
the other one yeah you know
for poops and kicks yeah yeah but so my
friends know that oh so also I can be a
normal man you know I put on my pants
two two ways I have pants I put them on
like sure I wear two ways two ways of
the pants yeah yeah yeah so you gotta
pay extra for pants you can wear two
ways thank you watch out for those Zips
that's right you yeah it's the word
that's the word also the brand
you that's right eight years yeah yeah
two of them
uh yes no so it's fine yeah yeah but
here's my argument with you Andy every
person has a public thing and a private
thing on some level some are insanely
crazy and then yeah you know yes there's
a deep there can be uh uh well I mean
there can be an extreme difference
between them Paul Reubens is a example
oh wow is Pee-wee Herman and Paul
Reubens and Paul Reubens is a very
different per very funny person yes but
a much more low-key person than PeeWee
Herman as one would hope yeah yeah let's
balance this puppy yes yes yeah so yeah
I mean because and like you're right
yeah there's a different I mean my
public Persona I feel like is just like
there's like when you have company over
that's you know what I mean yeah I'm
gonna put on some pants yeah I'm not
gonna go nuts you know yeah
I'm not gonna go crazy you know Martha
stewarding you out you know because I
just want to make you happy but you mean
insider trading I don't know no no I
mean just I I won't I my public Persona
is very close to me but it's more of a
presentable me I agree yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and and and do you feel
that that's well I am I think my public
is very uh positive and bubble crazy but
then my private I think to balance it
out is can be very dark but still in a
way that I think is funny so I I think
my humor switches I see yeah in private
at the Superdog and yeah in the public
because I'm like ah I think to use Conan
our mutual friend as an example I think
he doesn't delve into politics for
example on many things because like
what's the point right this does nothing
so when I'm super when I'm out I try to
be more positive because this is more
productive and proactive yes than the
dark stuff which to me is very funny yes
but I don't think it's not yes and it's
not no that's um
I I sound there was some questionnaire
thing I think it was for Team Coco that
I was doing and one of the questions was
was what's the funniest thing you've
ever
seen Conan do or something like that and
I said well it's not what he's done it's
what he said and it's never been it's
nothing that I can repeat or you know
because Conan at his funniness funniness
is
absolutely uh not for public consumption
and the same goes for almost every funny
person I know yes they say the worst
most awful things and I don't mean like
you know everyone's throwing the n-word
around I mean stuff like you know Murder
is good kind of things you know that
that sort of stuff yes
um but yeah no Conan at his funniest is
something that most people will probably
never see yeah yeah well if you're the
same I am I would say it's the same for
most people yes yeah yes well most funny
people well you know what your audience
is many many many people when you're
doing this but when you are private it's
those eight people who you understand
and know so you can say a thing that
those guys or girls will really enjoy
and sometimes it's just deeply
inappropriate in a funny way right right
yeah well you you know you you're
different the difference in your public
Persona in your and your private Persona
is that there is kind of this this
germanness there's this foreign Persona
oh yes and is that like does that do you
ever like does that ever cause you kind
of like any thoughts of like why have I
chosen to be an other
well I'm not this is me it's it's really
just taking the levels and going really
only and other within the terms of like
because when you come on the Conan show
you're not a you're not you're not a
comedian from New Jersey no that's true
you know Hoboken for this guy yes yes
like you are you're it it's you know the
fact that you are an other that you're
from a different country and that you
you use that yes you use that to your
advantage comedically I like to do the
thing that maybe would be the most
chaotic and fun for the situation yes so
I kind of just know you and Conan and
what you guys would what would be fun to
do yeah so that's what I played with you
but like with Kelly Clarkson I can't do
the exact same thing because it would go
devolving into chaos and darkness and
everyone would be confused we would go
to commercial very quick so you've got
bills to pay you can't do that on Kelly
have you been on Kelly Clarkson yes oh
that's wonderful yes but like that's is
I think maybe all of us do this like
like you I love to be with people I
loved I played basketball so I like to
be in a team and do what the team needs
and so I think it's very fun to try to
fit in and see what will work for each
thing I'm not always the same for all of
these different I see I see things so
yeah you know I can adjust the levels on
this insane German Harrier jet yes yes
yes